environ 50 000 à 70 000 personnes
qui vivent dans cette communauté de maisons
auto-construites à étages multiples
où jusqu'à trois générations par structure cohabitent.
Bien que ces appartements qu'ils se sont construits
semblent manquer de planification ou de zonage,
vu que chaque famille se spécialise dans une forme de recyclage,
le rez-de-chaussée de chaque appartement
est réservé aux activités liées aux déchets
et les étages du haut sont réservés à l'espace habitable.
Je trouve ça incroyable de voir
comment ces piles et ces piles de déchets
sont invisibles aux yeux des gens qui y vivent,
comme cet homme très distingué qui pose
pendant que tous ces déchets affluent derrière lui,
ou comme ces deux jeunes hommes qui sont assis
et qui discutent au milieu de ces tonnes de déchets.
Bien que pour la plupart d'entre nous, vivre parmi
ces piles et ces piles de déchets
peut sembler complètement inhabitable,
Pour les Zabbalîn, c'est juste
un autre aspect de ce qui est la normalité.
Dans tous ces endroits dont j'ai parlé aujourd'hui,
ce que je trouve vraiment fascinant c'est qu'en réalité
la normalité n'existe pas,
et cela prouve que les gens peuvent s'adapter
à toutes sortes de situations.
Durant la journée, il est très courant
de croiser une petite fête ayant lieu
dans la rue, comme cette fête de fiançailles.
Dans cette tradition, la future mariée
étale toutes ses possessions,
qu'ils apporteront bientôt à son nouveau mari.
Un assemblage comme celui-ci
permet cette juxtaposition
où toutes les choses nouvelles sont étalées
et tous les déchets sont utilisés
pour soutenir l'étalage des nouveaux accessoires du foyer.
Comme à Makoko ou dans la Torre David,
partout chez les Zabbalîn on trouve tous
les mêmes services que dans n'importe quel quartier.
Il y a les commerces au détail, les cafés
et les restaurants, et la communauté
est une communauté de chrétiens coptes,
donc on y trouve aussi une église,
avec une quantité d'icônes religieuses
un peu partout dans cette zone,
et aussi les services de tous les jours
comme les boutiques de réparation électronique,
les barbiers, tout ça.
La visite des foyers des Zabbalîn
est aussi pleine de surprises.
Bien que de l'extérieur, ces maisons
ressemblent à n'importe quelle autre structures informelles
de la ville, lorsqu'on y entre,
vous y trouvez toutes les sortes de choix de design
et de décoration intérieure.
Bien que leur accès à l'espace et à l'argent soit limité,
les maisons de cette zone sont conçues
avec soin et souci du détail.
Chaque appartement est unique,
et cette individualité raconte l'histoire
des circonstances et des valeurs de chaque famille.
La plupart de ces gens prennent très au sérieux
l'aménagement de leur maison et des espaces intérieurs,
ils mettent beaucoup de travail et de soin
dans chaque détail.
Les espaces communs sont aussi traités de la même façon,
où les murs sont décorés d'un motif imitant le marbre.
Mais malgré ce décor élaboré,
ces appartements sont parfois utilisés
de manières complètement inattendues
comme dans cette maison qui a attiré mon attention
alors que plein de boue et de foin s'écoulait littéralement vers l'extérieur
en dessous de la porte d'entrée.
Quand on m'a fait entrer, j'ai pu voir que cet appartement du cinquième étage
était transformé en une étable pour animaux,
six ou sept vaches ruminaient,
se tenant dans ce qui aurait été un salon.
Mais dans l'appartement de l'autre côté du couloir
en face de cet enclos à vache, un couple de jeunes mariés
vivent dans ce que les gens décrivent comme
l'un des plus beaux appartements du coin.
Ce détail m'a scié,
et alors que le propriétaire me faisait visiter
son appartement avec tant de fierté,
du sol au plafond, chaque morceau était décoré.
Et si ce n'était de l'odeur étrangement familière
qui vous retourne l'estomac
qui imprègne constamment l'appartement,
il serait facile d'oublier
que l'on se tient à côté d'un enclos à vache
et en haut d'une décharge.
Ce qui m'a le plus ému c'est que malgré
ces conditions d'apparence inhospitalière,
j'ai été accueilli à bras ouverts
dans une maison qui était construite avec amour, avec soin,
et avec une passion sans bornes.
Déplaçons-nous sur la carte, en direction de la Chine,
dans un coin appelé Shanxi, Henan et Gansu.
Dans une région reconnue pour le sol mou et poreux du plateau de Lœss,
jusqu'à tout récemment, on estime qu'il y avait
40 millions de personnes qui vivaient dans des maisons souterraines.
Ces logements sont appelés les yaodongs.
Avec cette architecture par soustraction,
ces yaodongs sont construits à l'intérieur du sol.
Dans ces villages, on voit un paysage complètement altéré
et, cachés derrière ces amoncellements de terre,
il y a ces maisons carrées, rectangulaires
qui se tiennent à sept mètres sous la surface.
Quand j'ai demandé aux gens pourquoi ils creusaient
leurs maisons dans le sol,
ils ont simplement répondu qu'ils sont de pauvres
cultivateurs de blé et de pommes, sans argent
pour acheter les matériaux de construction, et que de creuser ainsi
était la façon de vivre la plus logique pour eux.
De Makoko aux Zabbalîn, ces communautés
ont approché les tâches de planification,
de conception et de gestion de leurs communautés
et quartiers de manières qui répondent
de façon spécifique à leurs environnements et conditions de vie.
Etant créés justement par ces gens qui vivent,
travaillent et jouent dans ces espaces particuliers,
ces quartiers sont conçus intuitivement
pour tirer le meilleur parti de leurs circonstances.
Dans la plupart de ces endroits, le gouvernement
est complètement absent, ce qui laisse les gens
sans autre choix que celui de se réapproprier des matériaux qu'ils trouvent,
et bien que ces communautés soient fortement défavorisées,
c'est vrai qu'elles présentent des formes
d'ingénuité vraiment brillantes,
et elles prouvent qu'en effet, nous avons la capacité
de nous adapter à toutes sortes de conditions.
Ce qui rend des endroits comme la Torre David
particulièrement remarquables,
c'est cette sorte de cadre squelettique
d'où les gens peuvent trouver une fondation
et ce qu'ils en tirent.
Imaginez maintenant ce que ces communautés déjà ingénieuses
pourraient créer par elles-mêmes,
et combien leurs solutions seraient particulières,
si on leur donnait l'infrastructure de base,
ce qu'elles en tireraient.
De nos jours, on voit ces grands projets de développement résidentiel
qui offrent des solutions de logement toutes faites du même moule
à une énorme quantité de gens.
De la Chine au Brésil, ces projets essaient
de fournir le plus de logements possible,
mais elles sont complètement monotones
et ne fonctionnent tout simplement pas comme réponse
aux besoins individuels des gens.
J'aimerais terminer par une citation
d'une de mes amies et une source d'inspiration,
Zita Cobb, la fondatrice de la merveilleuse
fondation Shorefast,
située sur l'ile de Fogo, à Terre-Neuve.
Elle dit qu'il y a ce « fléau de l'uniformité
qui est en train de tuer la joie humaine »,
et je ne pourrais pas être plus d'accord avec elle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)